[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه اخبار الظهيره
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
روسيا تدمر موقعا لاوكرانيا فيزا
والبنتاغون يدرس
بقنابل بعيده المدى
الانتفاضه ضد خامنئي تصل الى عائلته
والنظام الايراني يستدعي اصلاحين بتهمه
التحريض
182 مليار
العراقي يعلن استعاده جزء من اموالي هيئه
الضرائب المنهوبه وانتقادات لمقترح عفو عن
الفاسدين
في المونديال الاسود المغرب نحو التاهل
ومنتخب السامبا يغيب عنه نيمار في مواجهه
سويسرا
مشاهدينا سنبدا من الحرب الاخرانيه حيث
تنظر وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون في
امكانيه تزويد اوكرانيا بقنابل صغيره تثبت
على صواريخ ويصلوا مداها الى 100 ميل طبعا
بحسب مقترح من شركه بوينج للصناعه
العسكريه رويترز ذكرت ان هذه القنابل
سعرها رخيص ايضا ستسمح لاوكرانيا ضربات
خلف الخطوط الروسيه رويترز اشارت الى ان
مقترح الشركه هو واحد من خطه البنتاجون
لامداد اوكرانيا وايضا دول اوروبا الشرقيه
بذخائر جديده ووثقا لهذا المقترح فان شركه
تعهدت بتسليم هذه القنابل الجديده في وقت
مبكر من ربي عام 20 23 طبعا في هذه
الاثناء قالت الدبلوماسيه في السفاره
الامريكيه في موسكو اليزابيث قالت ان
روسيا والولايات المتحده تمتلكا قنوات
لاداره المخاطر النوويه اضافت رد ان تع
تلك القنوات كان الهدف الجوهري من اللقاء
الذي جمع مديره وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
مع نظيره الروسي منتصف الشهر الجاري فيما
نفت المسؤوله الامريكيه علمها باللقاءات
المقبله وان كانت بالفعل هناك لقاءات
مجدوله كانت تقرير اعلاميه نقلت ان لقاء
منتظر بين الطرفين سيعقد في العاصمه
المصريه القاهره في الفتره من 29 نوفمبر
الى السادس من ديسمبر على كلن وكاله
نوفيستل للانباء افادت فيما يتعلق
بالتطورات الميدانيه على الارض بان
المدفعي الروسيه دمرت موقعا للجيش
الاوكراني في زبرجيا وقال مسؤول بالجيش
الروسي قال ان الموقع المستهدف كان
يستخدمه الجيش الاوكراني لمراقبه تحركات
القوات الروسيه هناك نافيا صحه الانباء عن
الانسحاب من المدينه ياتي هذا في ما تحدث
الجيش الاوكراني عن قصف روسي عنيف على
دينيرو جنوبيه البلاد كما افاد تقرير
اوكرانيه بان متعاونين مع الجيش الروسي
يغادرون طبعا منطقه منطقه نوفا كخوفكا قرب
خرسون وبدوره اكد الرئيس الامريكي اكد ان
القوات الروسيه تخطط لضربات جديده للاراضي
الاخرانيه راى ان وقوف الشعب الاوكراني
صفا واحدا هو مصدر القوه التي يستمدها على
كل دعانا متابعه
جديده نحن نعرف هذا على وجه الدقه وطالما
كانت لديهم صواريخ فلن يهداوا للاسف لكن
قدرتنا على مساعده بعضنا البعض والاعتناء
بمنهم في اصعب الاوضاع كبار السن والاسر
التي لديها اطفال ومن فقدوا منازلهم
واقاربهم بسبب الحرب مساعدتنا المتبادله
هي احد عناصر الحمايه من الارهاب وهي مصدر
قوتنا
مشاهدين هننتقل الان الى الملف الايراني
عضو البرلمان الايراني من مدينه مها باد
النائب جلال محمود زاديه دعا الى مساءله
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي ومساءله
وزير داخليه الجنرال احمد وحيد في اداره
الاضطرابات الاخيره في ايران النائب اشار
الى ان المساءله يجب ان تطال قرار اطلاق
النار على محتجين في المدن الكرديه خلال
حمله القمع التي تشنها السلطات لاخماط
طبعا الاحتجاجات التي تهز البلاد منذ 10
اسابيع طبعا هذه المطالبه النيابيه
للمسائله قبلها استدعاء للسلطات الايرانيه
الاثنين من قاده التيار الاصلاحي طبعا
بتهمه التحريض على النظام كان المركز
الاعلامي القضاء افاده الاسبوع الماضي
باستدعاء بعض الشخصيات الى النيابه العامه
لشرح ما سماه بنشر محتوى غير موثق وايضا
مسير
[موسيقى]
رامز رامز
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين
ويقابل هذه التحركات ايضا مشاهدينا العديد
من الاستعدادات تحركات ايضا في البرلمان
هناك حديث كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
لمساءله الرئيس الايراني من داخل البرلمان
الايراني على كل المزيد ينضم الينا في
الاستديو الباحث في الشان الايراني صالح
حميد اهلا بك استاذ صالح اسمح لي انا ابدا
بهذه المساءله والمطالبه بالمساءله اولا
البرلمان لدينا اصوات معتدله بالاصل ام
انه بحسب ما افهم هو مسيطر عليه من الصقور
اليس كذلك
بشكل كامل لكي يفوز انصار التيار المتجدد
الموالي المرشد الاعلى
ومعظم هؤلاء النوبهم ضباط سابقون في الحرس
الثوره حوالي 90 نائب منهم ما كانوا همم
موظفين او ضباط في الحرس
كذلك خبرنا عنه يعني اطار تخفيف الضغوط عن
الحكومه
ورابط هذه الاحتجاجات بان هناك بعض
المشاكل التقليلها بانها بعد المشاكل
المعيشيه لكن ما هو واضح ان هؤلاء النواب
اصلا هم جزء من هذه المنظومه الفاسده
والفشل في اداره يعني البلاد سواء من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه او المعيشيه سياسات
الداخليه والخارجيه هي التي ادت الى
اندلاع هذه الموجه غير المسبوقه من
الاحتجاجات
ما سمعناه عن هذه المساءله وما طرح هو فقط
فقاعات اعلاميه للاستهلاك الداخلي ليس الا
لن يكون لها تاثير او تحرك بالضبط
هؤلاء
النواب اغلبهم كانوا قد اصدروا بيانا
يطالبون باعدام المحتجين همم بعد ذلك
تراجعوا عنه عن البيان وطالبوا باجراء بعض
الاصلاحات والحوار مع المحتاجين وما الى
ذلك لكن كلها تاتي في اطار تخفيف الضغط
وليس استماع الى اصوات المحتجين واستجابه
مطالبهم يعني لان البرلمان عمليا ليس له
اي دور في ظل همم وجود مجلس مثل مجلس
صيانه الدستور الذي يفلتر المرشحين سواء
مرشح الرئاسه مرشحين البرلمان او المؤسسات
الاخرى يعني هذا وجود هذه
المؤسسات التي يجرف عليها المرشد بشكل
مباشر ويعين اعضائها يعني تبين مدى سيف
النظام الانتخابات او الديمقراطيه
الايراني
ليس له دور وبالمقابل لا يمثل الشارع حتى
لو كان كذلك لما هاجم المحتجون المكاتبها
هؤلاء النواب واحرقوها حتى في بعض المناطق
خاصه في المناطق الكرديه مثل
ايضا في شمال ايران محافظه
درعا التي شهدت البارحه ايضا مظاهرات
واسعه لذلك همم هذه الانتخابات مهندسه
الحكومه لا تمثل الشعب البرلمان مثل شعبي
لانه يمكن فيها منتفعه من هذا النظام ولكن
سؤال في ما يتعلق بالمعتدلين كان في صوت
معتدل بفتره من الفترات تم تحييد ام انه
فقط الشارع فيه وهل يمكن له ان يعود الان
يهتف بالمظاهرات ان هذه اللعبه منذ ليس في
هذه الاحتجاجات منذ احتجاجات 2019 يقول ان
لعبه الاصلاحين هكذا يصفونها الاصلاحين
والمتشددين كانت مجرد تبادل الادوار
الاستمراريه النظام الان ايضا هناك همم
انباء عن فتح حوارات الاصلاحين هم الذين
راسلوا المرشد خامعي ل- اا يقول ان يقول
له همم
مجددا لكن خانه قبل ثلاثه ايام في همم
تصريحاته الاخيره رد عليهم بشكل ضمني انا
لا نتفاوض مع الولايات المتحده والغير ولن
نسمع الى هذه همم الاصوات التي
ساعود اليك للحديث ولكن لا يمكن لنا الا
ان نتحدث عن هذه الدعوه اللافته التي
اطلقتها فريده مراد خاني طبعا فريده مراد
خاني خرجت مشاهدينا
بالتصريحات انتقدت فيها النظام فريده هي
ابنه شقيقه مرشد النظام الايراني علي
الخامنئي قبل يوم من اعتقالها خرجت بهذه
التصريحات فريده دعت العالم اجمع الى
مقاطعه النظام ودعم الشعب الايراني وفي
الفيديو الذي نشرتها قالت ابنته الشقيقه
خانني قالت ان الايرانيين يخوضون حربا مع
السلطات دعنا نتابع
هدومي الفجر
براس السلطه
نظام الحكم في ايران بانه ديكتاتوريه رجال
الدين
كلفته الملعب من ترشحه للانتخابات
النيابيه عام 2008
[تصفيق]
فريده مراد خالي ابنه شقيقه المرشد
الايراني علي خامني دفع ثمن دعوتها
الحكومات الاجنبيه الى قطع جميع علاقاتها
مع الحكومه الايرانيه اعتقالها بموجب امر
قضائي
حان الوقت
بحركه رمزيه عن طريق استدعاء جميع ممثليها
من ايران وترضي كل منتسب لهذا النظام
الوحشي كطريقه للتعبير عن التضامن مع
الشعب الايراني الساعي لنيل الحريه
سلسله الاعتقالات التي يقدم عليها نظام
الايراني ضد كل ما يعارضه شامله ايضا
شخصيات ذات علاقه مباشره مع مسؤولين
السابقين احد تلك الامثله فائزه هاشم رصا
جونيا لابنه الثانيه للرئيس الايراني
الاسبق علي اكبر هاشم رفا سنجر المعروفه
بطفله الثوره الزوج بها في السجن بتهمه
التحريض على الاحتجاج في الشوارع اضافه
الى اتهامها بنشاط الدعائي ضد النظام وفقا
لوكاله تسليم الرسميه الايرانيه
ايه ده المشاهدين التحركات على الارض
مستمره دعونا ننتقل الى مدينه الزهدان
وهذه هي المقاطع التي ننقلها طبعا هذه
المدينه في محافظه بلوشستان الايرانيه عدد
كبير من النساء سنشاهد هذا الفيديو الان
عدد كبير من النساء وهن يحملن لافتات هذه
اللافتات كما نشاهد تطالب باسقاط النظام
وايضا بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن حملات القمع
ضد المحتاجين طبعا التظاهرات في اكثر من
مدينه والان سنتابع هذه الصور من قلب
العاصمه الايرانيه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
تعالوا تعال
وا شهر يا راسي شهرزاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المشاهدين كما تابعنا تظاهرات على الارض
وايضا انتقادات وصلت الى قلب العائله التي
في طبعا فيديو شاهدناه قبل قليل لينتقد
المواجهه والقمع الذي يتعرض له المحتج في
الشارع ويعود الى ضيف صالح حميد حول هذه
النقطه اهميه مثل هذا التصريح طبعا فريده
علي مراد هاني المعروف بالشيخ علي
الطهراني وكان معرضا صريحا لخامنه همم هو
زوج اخته وتوفى قبل اشهر همم كان ايضا من
المعارضين الذين ذهبوا الى العراق واسسه
هناك بالحرب العراقيه الايرانيه اذاعه
بالفارسيه مواجهه الايراني ثم بعد ذلك
التفاوضت تفاوض معه
عاد لا يرى لكن سجنه في البدايه ثم وضعه
تحت الاقامه الجبريه حتى هذا التصريح من
همم يعني العائله المقربه همم تعني ان
هناك ولنقساما همم داخل النظام حول كيفيه
التعامل مع الاحتجاجات ثانيا الكشف تاكيد
الجرائد
انقسام داخل النظام هل تعتبر هي جزء من
هذا النظام او لا معارضه وتسير بخطه
والدها همم
والدها لكن وجودها هكذا اشخاص بالقرب من
راس النظام يعني ان هناك اصواتا منتقده
بعضهم يتجرا مثل فريده مرت خالي وترفع
صوتها وتدفع الثمن سجنت ثوره يعني همم
نشرها الفيديو والبعض صامتون نرى الكثير
من الشخصيات غير راضيه ولكنها صامته لا
تريد همم يكون مصيرها نفس همم مصير فريده
مراد لكن هذا يعني ان هناك اختلافا كبيرا
في كيفيه التعاطي من اي ما زال متعمده على
حال الامنيه خاطب البسيج ليس يقول الامن
ولا حتى الحرس الثوري دعاهم الى استمرار
القمع وهذا يعني انه يريد ان يستمر بهذا
النهج هو نفس النهج الذي همم ساعده النظام
السوري على رقم شعبه وفي العراق كذلك
ولبنان ومناطق اخرى
الى السجن هل له ان يدفع الاخرين للخروج
والحديث او انه لا بالفعل هذه السياسه
بالنهايه ستقمع كل من سيحاول حتى التعبير
عن رايك
يكذب علينا قال ان المتظاهرين يريدون حرق
القران واستهداف القيم الدينيه لكن شاهدنا
الفيديوهات التي خرجت من بلوشستان مثلا
نساء محجبات زي البلوشي المحلي
وفريده مرت خالي بحجابها والناس حتى كانت
هناك محجبات تحركنا صور خامنه وتكتبنا
شعراء ضد النظام وهذا يعني ان كل فئات
الشعب سواء المتدينين او الذين لا يريدون
الحجاب كلهم موحدون حول مطالبهم برحيل هذا
النظام وعدم شرعيته لانه يقتل شعبه يستمر
في هذا الحل ولا يريد ان يستجيب لي مطالب
الشارع
ولو والاعتقالات طالت الجميع حتى بخلفيات
رياضيه سنتحدث عنها طبعا بالاستديو كان
معنا ضيفنا والمختص والباحث في الشان
الايراني صالح حميد شكرا جزيلا لك وبالفعل
في هذا الاطار مشاهدينا اسطوره كره القدم
الايرانيه علي الدائي تعرض لتهديدات
مختلفه هو واسرته طبعا من قبل جهات وصف
هذا اللاعب الرياضي الشهير هذه الجهاد
بالمجهوله وكان علي داء كتب تعليقا على
مقتل الشابه مهسا اميني ايه اتهم النظام
بتدمير البلاد تساءل عما يمكن له ان يجيب
ابنته حول تساؤلاتها عما حدث لمهزه وباي
ذنب قتلت يذكر ان اعالج الدائري طبعا هو
همم النجم الملاعب الايرانيه سابقا هو
افضل هداف في تاريخ المنتخب الايراني
واللاعب الذي تجاوز المئه هدف دوله
على كل الناس في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد
قليل
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان يعلن ان
اعاده العلاقات مع مصر ستبدا باجتماع وزري
متابع معنا
الاخبار الظهيره من الملف المصري التركي
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اكد ان
اعاده بناء العلاقات مع مصر ستبدا باجتماع
للوزراء لحل القضايا الثنائيه اردوغان
اضافه ان العلاقه مع سوريا يمكن ان تعود
ايضا الى طبيعتها مثل ما جرى مع مصر
معتبرا ان تركيا لديها حق التصرف خارجه
حدودها لحمايته امنيه
القدر
مشاهدينا الان الى العراق وتحديدا الحديث
عن ملف استرداد الاموال المنهوبه بدات
تظهر اراء مثيره للجدل المتعلقه بالعفو عن
الفاسدين فبينما وقف خبراء قانوني ضد
تخفيف العقوبات عن الفاسدين لتمكين
الحكومه من محاسبتهم 10 اخرون الى ضروره
اصدار عفو عن الفاسدين المقابله اجبارهم
على تسليم الجزء الاكبر من الاموال التي
سرقوها سيسهم باستعاده تلك الاموال يشجع
على فتح صفحه جديده يمكن للحكومه من
خلالها ومن بعدها ان تقوم بتشديد العقوبات
على المدنين بالرشوه وسرقه المال العام
طبعا رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني كان اعلن استبداد جزء من حوالي
2.5 مليار دولار من الاموال المسروقه من
الامانات الضريبيه التي كانت محور قضيه
فساد كبرى تم الكشف عنها منذ ايام
السوداني اشار الى انه تم تشكيل لجان
تحقيق لتد السقوق المصروفه من الامانات
الضريبيه متابعه ارقام
مجموعه ثلاثه مليون
و754 مليار
و642 مليون
و664 الف دينار عراقي
وفق الاعترافات او اللجنه التدقيق الاولين
طبعا
مجلس الوزراء قرار بالتعاقد مع شركه تدقيق
عالميه هذا عمل ثاني لزياده الاطمئنان حتى
نعرف
مقدار المبالغ المسروق
المزيد معنا من عمان المحلل السياسي
العراقي باسل حسين الغويري اهلا بك سيد
باسل اسمح لي ان ابدا بالصوره التي
شاهدناها للاموال وجزء منها المسروق ما
الذي يراد من خلال اظهار هذه الاموال من
خلال هذا التصريح
في رساله خاطئه لانه هناك يبدو منهج
تصالحي مع الفساد هذا يعطي رساله
[موسيقى]
ثم التصالح معهم وعقد الصفقات لكن الصفقات
ليس بمعناها لايجابي لكن بمعنى الرفث
لانهم من الصعوبه همم هذا المنهج التصالح
من الفساد همم
هو مكافحه
البعض يقول قانونيا قضيه همم العفو عنهم
بحال سلم وان كان لا تسقط كل القضايا عنهم
هو امر قانوني وطبيعي وربما اظهار هذه
لشوالات اذا ما صحت تعبير من الاموال
رساله للقول بانه على الاقل سنحصل على
الاموال الاولويه الان بالنسبه للعراق
عوده هذه الاموال او المحاسبه
بل الطريقه يعني مطلوبات يعني اولا ينبغي
الضرب بيدنا حديد عن الفاسدين لانه همم
الفساد اصبح جزء من بنيه النظام السياسي
النظام السياسي في ينكتب عنه النظام اصبح
كثير واقراطي النظام لصوصي وبالتالي ينبغي
تحسين هذه الصوره الى اراد احد مكافحه
الفساد لا ان يتخذ منهج التصالح يعني ومن
هنا يعني المنطق الاختلاف الاموال المطلوب
استرجاعها لكنه بالتاكيد ليس على حساب همم
سياسه مكافحه الفساد همم المناهج التصالحي
مع الفساد يعني انه سيشجع الفاسدين
المستقبلا على المضيء همم
بحجه ارجاع الفاسدين ممكن
تكرار عمليات الفساد لاكثر من همم مره
يعني اعتقد المنهج لن يكون همم حجم
اموال المنهوبه بالامس مصادر النيابيه
تتحدث عن التثبيت مليار ذهبت نتيجه مشاريع
سحبت لمشاريع وهميه تصور هذه المبلغ من
مصادر نيابيه تقول ان المبلغ اللي سحب
مشاريع متلكيا اللي بحدود 6600 مشروع وهمي
او متلكا سحبت من اجل 300 مليار دولار لكن
لا نتيجه على الارض وبالتالي
السياسه
[موسيقى]
بالعراق للاسف لن نتحدث فقط عن مشاريع
وهميه ولكن ايضا حتى عن اشباح كم موظفين
كانوا يدفع لهم الاموال والموضوع مفتوح
للنقاش من عمان المحلل السياسي العراقي
باسل حسين الغريري شكرا جزيلا لك
من العراق الى اليمن
قوات الشرعيه وسائل الاعلام تابعه
لمليشيات الحوثي ذكرت ان الميليشيات اجرت
عديد العمليات التشييع لقتلها في عده
محافظات يمنيه منهم في امانه العاصمه
وحدها وتمنحهم رتب عسكريه مختلفه وذلك
خلال يوم واحد على كلن اخبار الظهيره
مستمره وفيها ولكن بعد قليل في السودان
منظمات امنيه تحذر من كارثه في قطاع
التعليم ولجنه المعلمين تبدا اليوم اضرابا
عن العمل
الانتفاضه الداخليه الى عائلته والنظام
الايرانيه يستدعي اصلاحين بتهمه التحريض
اته
وفي المونديال
ومنتخب السامبا يغيب عنه نيمار في مواجهه
سويسرا
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم مجددا ونكمل اخبار
الظهيره من السودان اليوم تبدا لجنه
المعلمين السودانيين اضرابا جزئيا عن
العمل يتبعه حرائق قد يصل الى الاضراب
العام اذا لم تلبس سلطات مطالبهم قالت
لجنه المعلمين انها استنفدت كافه السبل
القانونيه مع الجهات المعنيه لتحقيق
مطالبه المتمثله في رفع الحد الادنى
للاجور تتوقع لجنه المعلمين مشاركه غالبيه
المعلمين البالغ عددهم 240000 عموم
السودان سيشمل الاضراب حوالي 20 الف مدرسه
للمراحل الابتدائيه
والمتوسطه والثانويه حول هذا الاضراب معنا
من الخرطوم مراسله العربيه لنا يعقوب اهلا
بكين لنا وكل لنا الاجواء والمعلومات
المتوفره لديك امام مدرسه مغلقه فيما يبدو
اهلا بك يا ميسون صباح الخير نعم لجنه
المعلمين تتحدث عن استجابه واسعه لهذا
الاضراب الذي دعت له لمده يوم واحد على ان
تتخذ اجراءات اخرى يوم الخميس المقبل
ومنها تقرر قمنا بجوله على المدارس بعض
المدارس نفذت فعلا الاضراب بصوره شبه
كامله وهناك استجابه ضعيفه في مدارس اخرى
لجنه المعلمين تتحدث ان الاضراب همم شامل
في الخرطوم وفي الولايات السودانيه سبب
هذا الاضراب ميسون رفع الحد الادنى للاجور
هناك مذكره طلبتها همم لجنه ارسلتها
لحد الادنى عندما تتحرك الكاميرا
عندما تتحرك الكاميرا يتقطع الصوت
اذا نكمل فهذا هذه مدرسه من المدارس
الاستجابه فيها ليست كبيره ولكن هناك
استجابه اخرى في مدارس بصوره كامله كما
يظهر ان الان التلاميذ يتحركون في المدرسه
وهناك الان ميسون مشاورات بين المعلمين
ماذا يتخذون ما هي القرارات المقبله التي
يمكن اتخاذها هل يكون هذا الاضراب ليوم
اخر جديد علما بان هذا الاضراب فقط هو
اليوم الاثنين ام ان هناك اجراءات اخرى قد
تتخذها الجهات المعنيه من بينها وزاره
الماليه
وسنتابع تطورات لنا يعقوب من الخرطوم
مراسله العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
ومش شاهدتيني
على كل مشاهدينا من السودان الى اليمن
تحديدا تعز حيث يشكي العديد من النازحين
هناك من برد الشتاء القارس في ظل افتقارهم
للملابس للاحتياجات الاساسيه للعيش داخل
المخيمات التفاصيل في هذا التقرير
عليهم التغلب على قسوه العيش في المخيم
فهذه الاسر التي هجرت منازلها قبل عوامل
بسلاح المليشيات من القدح غربا تسارع
اليوم الفقر بالتسول بحثا عن ما يسده
شديده بسبب البرد
هذا الذي نعاني من نوع هذه الايام
والاطفال يعانون من الحميات والامراض بسبب
الصقور والزكام
هذا لا كوثر ولا مالح ولا معنا اي حاجه
ناس اسحب منها البئر
عايشين يعني على حاجه كره
الضروره اللي عملنا احنا عشره طول الاطفال
في هذه المخيمات ليس لديهم ملابس توقيهم
برد الشتاء مضطر عائلتهم الى عدم ارسالهم
للمدارس والمنظمه الانسانيه لا تلبي
احتياجاتهم الاساسيه
يعني
نروح المدرسه
في هذه السنه بالذات قلت الدعم قلت
المنظمات التي تحضر اليهم لدعمهم
لمساندتهم ولدهم يعانون من مشاكل كبيره
حتى يعانون في قضايا الامراض
التيتهم في تعز والساحل الغربي يعانون من
افتقارهم للغذاء والماء والدواء وهو امر
فاقم من معاناتهم في المخيمات السعيد
العربيه تعز الدوحه اهلا بك ليس صباح
الخير يعني اجواء الفرح لا زالت مستمره
حتى اللحظه في الاجواء هنا بفوز المنتخب
المغربي ماذا عن الاجواء لديك تفضل
الرياح قويه
وهي منطقه تبعد 50 كيلو متر عن الدوحه
العاصمه القطريه ولكن جئنا الى هناك من
تشاهدين العالم المكسيكي خلفي لماذا لان
المكسيك سوف تلتقي السعوديه الاربعاء
المقبل والمنتخب المكسيكي طلب تناول وجبه
غداء سعوديه
المنتخب المكسيكي تناول غداء اليوم ولذلك
جئنا نرصد اذا امكن ان نشاهد وصول هذه
الوجبات الى الفريق المكسيكي الذي يريد ان
يتعرف على ثقافه السعوديه من خلال الوجبات
التي يتناول التي تتناول في السعوديه واذا
شفنا هون مقابل المنتجع الذي يسكن فيه
الفريق المكسيكي نشاهد لوحات نشاهد حضاره
المايا التي تعرض على هذه اللوحه امامي
والعالم المكسيكي والمناطق المكسيكيه همم
كهذه يعني ال- ال-
اللوحه التي نشاهد وكذلك نشاهد الحضاره
القطريه كيف يمكن يعني كيف امكن همم في
هذه المنطقه الجمع بين الحضرتين في
المونديال واذا اخذنا الكاميرا الى هذه
الجهه سوف نشاهد الحافلات هناك تقيم او
يقيم المنتخب المكسيكي في هذا الماء في
هذا المنتجع البحري في منطقه سمسمه وكذلك
سوف يعني نحاول رصد اذا امكن وصول وجبات
الوجبات السعوديه الى هذا الفريق الذي
سيتناول طبعا وجبه الغذاء لطهر اليوم هنا
في قطر واذا شاهدنا في عمق الصوره نشاهد
هناك الاستاذ البيت البيت الشعر الذي يقع
طبعا مع الهواء القوي والرياح والرمال من
الصعب يمكن مشاهده ذلك على الشاشه ولكن
هذا بيت البيت الشعر او استاد او ملعب بيت
الشعر الذي لا يبعد عن منطقه
في قطر وهذه الاجواء لدينا وسوف طبعا نرصد
حاول اذا امكن اذا تم ادخال هذه الوجبات
من هذه البوابه الرئيسيه سوف نرصد ذلك بكل
تاكيد او سالتك عن اجواء المغرب من
المفترض انه الاحتفالات هناك بقيت حتى
السادسه صباحا خبرنا ليث
يعني نمنا ثلاث ساعات لانه راسا بعد ما
حضرنا وخلصنا كان عندنا صباح العربيه صباح
اليوم توقيت دبي ولذلك طبعا الاحتفالات
يعني شهدنا اشياء كثيره احتفالات دامت
لاكثر من 11 ساعه مباشره من الملعب الى
الى الى ساحه سوق واقف التي تحولت كانه
ساحه جامع عرفنا في مراكش كان هناك الكثير
من المشجعين العرب شفت السعوديون همم شفنا
القطريون شفنا الكويتيون شفنا من اليمن من
فلسطين كثير اجوا حاملين العالم الفلسطيني
تشجيعا للمنتخب المغربي وطبعا شاهدنا كيف
انه كانت الاحتفالات بدون توقف يعني كل
دقيقه كان توصل افواج وافواج من الجماهير
ليس فقط مغاربه اعود واكرر ولكن طبعا
الكثير من المغاربه والكثير منهم اتو فقط
لتشييع يعني المنتخب المغربي ولم يدخل الى
الملعب التي اقيمت فيها فيه المباراه بين
المغرب
لو سمحت العربيه
شكرا جزيلا لك ويعطيكم الف عافيه
هذا يخطط اتحاد الكره الروسي للانتقال
للاتحاد الاسيوي لكره القدم بدلا من
الاوروبي وفق رئيس مجلس الاداره الكزاندرد
ايقاف في وقت ساب تم استبعاد كل الفرق
الروسيه سواء المنتخبات في الانديه من
المشاركه في مسابقات الاتحادين الدولي
وايضا الاوروبي وجاء ذلك تزامنا طبعا مع
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا على
كلن رغم ايضا الهجمات والتفجيرات التي
تشهدها العاصمه الصوماليه مقاديش بين
الحين والاخر الا ان الصوماليين يتابعون
ايضا مباريات كاس العالم عبر شاشات عرض
توفرها بعض المطاعم املينا ان تنتهي
متابعتهم للمونديال لمونديال قطر بامن
وسلام دعنا
[موسيقى]
الا بعد خطوات من موقع التفجير الدامي
الذي قتل فيه قبل نحو شهر اكثر من 120
شخصا واصابه اكثر من 300 اخرين يتابع
هؤلاء صوماليون مباريات كاس العالم في قطر
لم يمنعهم الخوف من التفجيرات من الاهتمام
بالحدث العالمي في رساله تحدي تؤكد انهم
جزء من هذا العالم مهما كانت الظروف
انا سعيد جدا لمتابعه المباريات بشكل دائم
وساشاهدها حتى النهايه ونتمنى انه هي
المتابعه بسلام ويرى كثير من هؤلاء ان
مشاهده كاس العالم بشكل جماهير في مقرشه
تدور املي بحد ذاته والدليل على ان الوطن
الامنيه في تحسننا وان كانت امنياتهم
تتجاوز مشكله الامن
قبل سنوات
في هذه الاماكن ومتابعه كاس العالم بشكل
جماعي الحمد لله الان اتابع المونديال مع
الجماهير وامنوا ان يكون منتخب بلادي يوما
ما من المتاهلين لكاس العالم
هذه المتابعه الجماعيه دليل على التحسن
الامني الذي تشهده مدينه مقديشو والتطور
الذي تشهده البلاد بشكل عام ونتطلع الى ان
نكون جزء من هذه المسابقه الدوليه
المستقبلانا
تجذبهم الساحره المستديره هربا من هموم
العنف المتجدد احيانا في مقديشو فرجه
طبقهم في تواصل مع العالم على مدى شهر
واملهم الا يحدث ما يعكر الصف متعتهم هذه
عبد الرحمن البخاري العربي
اذن الصوماليون يتابعون كره القدم وقوات
الامن الصوماليه تتابع شيء اخر هناك
محاصره لفندق يقع وسط العاصمه مقديش حيث
يتحسن عناصر حركه الشباب وذلك منذ ليله
امس قوات الامن ذكرت ان الحصار اسفر عن
مقتل اربعه اشخاص لا يزال يسمع عدويه
انفجارات واطلاق نار في ساعات الصباح
الاولى حول هذا الفندق الذي يرتديه عاده
البرلمانيون وكبار المسؤولين ويقع على
مسافه قريبه جدا من مكاتب الرئيس الصومال
حسن شيخ محمود ياتي هذا فيما علق البرلمان
الصومالي جلسته اليوم بسبب الوضع الامني
الان مشاهدينا الى فاطمه واخبار الظهيره
الاقتصاديه فاطمه تفضلي
شكرا
شكرا لا ميسون ودعونا قناه دراما مفصله
على تداولات الاسواق ال في المنطقه وايضا
الاسواق العالميه هذه الصوره الان نراها
سلبيه بالمجمل سوق السعوديه خفضت جزءا ما
من خسارها كنا بدانا الجلسه على تراجعات ب
200 نقطه تقريبا وايضا تحدثنا عن استمرار
ضعف السيوله يوم امس بالكاد نتحدث عن
اثنين ونصف مليار ريال تم تنفيذها بالسوق
هذه ادنى رايناها منذ فبراير 20 20 الان
المؤشر يتراجع بشكل خفيف يعود فوق مستوى
ال 10.700 نقطه باقي ال- الاسواق ايضا
تسجل تراجعات على السبب رئيسي وراء ذلك
ايضا هو تراجع الحادث اللي شفناه في اسعار
النفط والذي يكمل التصحيح للاسبوع الثالث
على التوالي همم اسبوع الماضي تحدثنا عن
اداء سلبي وهذا بيعطينا ثلاث اسابيع على
توالي من حيث التراجع براند كان خاسر
تقريبا اربعه ونصف في المئه نائمكس ايضا
بتراجع بنفس النسبه محينا همم ارباح هذه
السنه نايكس عادل القلب اذا ما تحدثنا عن
اداء سنوي وبرنس بالكاد ان يتحدث عن
ارتفاع خفيف بحدود الاربعه في المئه الوضع
في الصين يضغط بشكل كبير ارقام تباطؤ
النمو الاقتصاد العالمي اا تضغط ايضا
الصوره بالنسبه للسنه القادمه فيها الكثير
من التحديات
والاحتجاجات مستمره في الصين في ابرز
المدن الرئيسيه على راسها شانجهاي ضد
سياسه السفر تقرير صدر صباح هذا اليوم من
جولدن ساكس يقول انه يتوقع ان يعود
الاقتصاد الصيني للعمل بشكل كامل قبل
ابريل من العام القادم وواضح احتمال 30%
انه سوف يتوقف عن هذه السياسه همم قبل
نهايه الربع الثاني من العام القادم اسواق
اسيا تغلق على تراجعات هنك بعد ما كان
افتتح على تراجعات باربعه في المئه يغلق
على خسائر بواحد ونصف نقطه مئويه مع الرغم
من البنك المركزي الصيني مستمر في استخدام
كل الادوات
امامه من حيث السياسه النقديه والماليه
لضخ المزيد من السيوله في السوق وفي
الاقتصاد اخرها كان هو تخفيض القرار بحدود
ال 25 نقطه اساس وذلك لضخ المزيد من
السيوله خصوصا في القطاع العقاري ااا
اسواق اوروبا تفتتح على تباين ولكن معظمها
تاخذ الاشارات من الجلسه السلبيه الصباحيه
في اسيا كاكاونت يخسر حوالي نصف نقطه
يتراجع بحدود الصفر فصل 3% ويبقى دولار من
ومن يرتفع مقابل سله من العملات الرئيسيه
مع ان الصوره بدات تسع حسن بعض الشيء
لصالح اليورو مثلا الذي يعود ليس فيها
بحدود الصفا صلاه ال 3% بعد الهدوء على
حركه الدولار التي رايناها صباح هذا اليوم
انا عود معكم بالاسواق العربيه نحلل كل
هذه الاخبار ما الان عوده الى ميسون
شكرا فاطمه صحه زعيم كوريا
ابنته الى اجتماع مع علماء متخصصين في
مجال الصواريخ طبعا هذا ثاني ظهور علني
لها ما ادى الى تعميق الجدل بالخارج حول
ما اذا كانت سترشح خليفه
البالغه من العمر عشر سنوات كل الاخبار
الخاصه بكوريا الشماليه اصبحت محور
اهتمامها ممسكه بذراع والدها ومرتديه
معطفا اسود مثله تماما ملامحها تشبهه حد
التطابق فهي ابنته المدلله هو التي وصفتها
وسائل الاعلام الكوريه الشماليه بانها
الاقرب الى قلبه من بين ابنائه الثلاثه
مستخدمه تعابير الابنه العزيزه ومحبوبتك
ظهرت شو ايه وهي تقف الى جانب الزعيم
المثير للجدل في منتصف صف من الجنود امام
صاروخ ضخم موضوع فوق شاحنه اطلاق فيما
بدات في صور اخرى وهي تصفق للجلود
والعلماء وسائل اعلام كوريا الجنوبيه سبق
وتكهنت بان للزعيم الكوري الشمالي ثلاثه
اطفال وان الطفل الاول ذكر بينما ثالث
انثى
وكانت الابنه المحبوبه ظهرت للمره الاولى
الاسبوع الماضي عندما نشرت وسائل الاعلام
الكوريه الشماليه صورا لها ممسكه بيد
والدها خلال اطلاق سبعه اشهر الظهور
الثاني لجوء اثار التكهنات المتعلقه
بانتقال السلطه مستقبلا في كوريا الشماليه
فيما راى خبراء ان كيم اراد الدعايه
لصاروخه الجديد من خلال الجيل الجديد
مضيفين انه سيواصل تقديم ابنته في مناسبه
العده كاداه للدعايه
في هيئه الاذاعه البريطانيه بي بي سي
للاعتداء من قبل الشرطه الصينيه قبل
اعتقاله خلال احتجاجات على اجراءات كورونا
قبل 19
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
روسيا تدمر موقعا لاوكرانيا في زابوريجيا
والبنتاغون يدرس تزويد بقنابل
الانتفاضه ضد الضفه مني تصل الى عائلته
والنظام الايراني يستدعي الاصلاحين بتهم
التحريض
العراق يعلن استعاده جزء من اموالي هيئه
الضرائب المنهوبه وانتقادات لمقترح عفو عن
الفاسدين
في المونديال الاسود المغرب نحو التاهل
ومنتخب السامبا يغيب عنه نيمار في مواجهه
سويسرا
نلتقي غدا ونشر جديده مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]